[Music]
that wasn't supposed to happen news
submitted by Tracy Kay I think that's a
lot of kids a gender-reveal party turned
tragic when a woman was killed in an
explosion oh no the fireworks not the
mom grandmother oh my god
thank God it out of everyone that was
take care of the oldest one I would love
to cut to that that when they're
cleaning up from the party it's just so
dark to think of it it's not even the
party it's before the party it's [ __ ]
up Rita Meeta me okay you seen this yeah
I heard about it I read about it it was
cuz the bomb was going off and the crowd
was too slow to run away huh no she was
actually like 44 yards away or something
oh yeah so 45 feet my butt
oh yeah she got a heart attack maybe
smoke grenade and she choked no I can
tell you okay cuz we almost all choked
yeah for sure way to get out of there
where the [ __ ] smoke bombs
extra-small evacuate for a second jeez
so anyways mom the soon-to-be
grandmother was killed at gender-reveal
party in Iowa because she was struck in
the head by shrapnel all of her family
inadvertently created a pipe bomb oh god
that's so extremely no but they didn't
they didn't know like okay so the way
they did it
I just bought a couple ma T's in there
it was made out of a metal tube that was
welded to a metal base plates and had a
hole drilled in the side of the tube for
a fuse the tube was then filled with
gunpowder and a cold gunpowder colored
powder and then covered with the board
and it was wrapped over the top of the
metal tubing creating a pipe bomb DIY
Baha
powder shooting the powder at the top of
the stand loaded sending metal pieces
flying so then the grandmother she was
standing with family members about 45
feet away from the device when it
exploded in it she was hit in the head
by a piece of shrapnel causing instant
death oh it's good and then they're
saying that that suffer piece that
killed her continued to travel another
although they're 144 yards through the
air Oh mine going through a field final
destinations yeah that's kind of good
physics I don't know that they could
calculate that oh yeah they can
calculate how fast things were going how
it entered yeah just based off of the
[ __ ] impact huh did you ever see
Dexter that's what I did well I did see
it but I forgot did anybody go to the
guy after him - Hannah that's that's boy
thinking of the after [ __ ] how do you
sir maybe in the moment they were all
celebrating because they saw the thing
right let me see grab it it's so fast
I'm a lean on the full grandma wake up
what you doing down there I heard or
read or both that they were
experimenting making the [ __ ] and that's
when I exploded like they were testing
out to make the thing before the actual
[ __ ] that one I don't have they're just
saying that it set off at a
gender-reveal party I mean how do you
see this is why it's difficult and I
always promote people to [ __ ] leave
their families because how do you
control how [ __ ] your family is like
it's probably like uncle Ernie's family
that you're just like [ __ ] we got to go
to that [ __ ] thing alright we'll go
and you're like man they're always
[ __ ] losers though and then you get
there and then they do this [ __ ] and
grandma dies all because of [ __ ] dis
mother because he wanted a blue powder
for social media for social he didn't
grab you a man in los grams are these
people as Joe would say probably
probably do they have him in Iowa what I
guess yeah so uh yeah there are forty
miles southwest of Des Moines
she was 66 years old oh yeah there's a
really good Peruvian restaurant in Des
Moines it's amazingly really authentic
it popped into my head it's really and
we ate there with David and this lady
she the owner she's from Peru and really
like best Peruvian food yet is in Des
Moines yeah I'll check that order I had
like this the soup where it's like kind
of like um it's like a seafood soup but
it's kind of broth it's kind of thick
yeah
and we had bisque almost yeah all was
Biscay and then we had like the the beef
[ __ ] the Lomo saltado yeah yeah yeah
well what would you do in this situation
well you know you have some [ __ ] Oh
piss that whoever made it no no like Oh
even going to these things like [ __ ] I
gotta go to this figured I mean they
just figured they had covered enough
distance between the true object in them
yeah
44 feet that's pretty far no that looks
like a pretty cool DIY they can't be
weird she's so young thanks this is her
this is the weapon that killed her 66
that's like my parents age my mom's
older than her sheesh
that's sad super sad so now it's just
like a lot of people are talking about
like really do like you guys got a
[ __ ] chill on the gender-reveal party
it's gonna remember that fire that
happened they there was this fire that
burned 47 thousand acres of the the the
corner corner I can't do it
Coronado National Forest she was Jessica
wrong I love with things that are
supposed to be a big celebration go
wrong it's so extreme right it's funny
because you know they're trying to like
do some next-level [ __ ] and they're so
happy about it and it just [ __ ] makes
the best moment of their lives turn to
the tragic moment I think a year --zz
ago this fire he was an off-duty u.s.
Border Patrol agent and so when they
were revealing that the wife was
carrying a baby boy that's when he used
a high-powered rifle to shoot at a
target
causing an explosion with blue substance
so then uh now or like getting some
really catches on fire pretty much all
because it's cuz he had packed the
target with tannerite
my friend Richard uses in his videos
it's tight yeah the chicken [ __ ]
Kapow
he pleaded guilty in September of last
year and to federal charges so he was
sentenced to five years probation in
order to pay 8.1 million dollars she how
can you even pay that much your salary
as a police officer wouldn't you won't
even make that much you might decide to
do overtime until you die yeah you threw
an eight point 1 million dollar general
review party right that wasn't even that
fire yeah did you feel well no I didn't
even mean to do that and I hate myself
did you guys I'm gonna wallow in self
hatred yeah did you have a gender reveal
yeah we had you're really sure no it was
so that was the bass dude your mom way
of ham yeah she she ran up with a silly
string and [ __ ] double [ __ ] so your
mom let me let me like level it up and
make my presence known and then later
she passes out your [ __ ] ovaries are
really issues is she into attention ho
no no no no perfect she's just in this
is crazy
she just wants to energy to be really
positive so she does everything in our
power to try because it's not even
positive it's like heightened extreme
positive to the point where it's
delusional it's borderline a soul yeah
yeah moms get weird when this new
company around you know I'm seeing when
it's what you know like my mom
specifically when she's having people
over or she's like where we know we're
gonna have like a bunch of people for
dinner she could sit here like a very
jumpy and like her Energy's just like
like strange
oh you know the squirrel it's kind of
like they're afraid of judgment like how
the house looks and this and that people
just want to eat and have fun
yeah but they're talking all but my mom
does that in a weird way
oh she gets all okay got to make some
slime so they eat it slime yeah like I'm
[ __ ] lotus root slime [ __ ] Wow
like if she like got it oh let's get
some pie there's no way you say no I
don't know it's funny that this is how
positive this woman is right she'll make
slime [ __ ] chia seed whatever thing
right and I think in her head she's
expecting people to go oh thank god
there's something healthy here thank you
I want to try some Lotus see this is the
worst pitch ever you want to try that
[ __ ] they're like yeah try some slime
yeah I mean when he said Lotus and [ __ ]
I was like I've never had lotus leaf
slime before yeah it's down yes I'm down
you know I'm gonna have a choice okay
you do for your second kid gender
fireworks yep I know some Dana's on fire
and then whatever color the smoke is
that's called gender arson I like it
we're not gonna
she doesn't want to know the gender
until the baby I can't wait you're
underprepared
Casey doesn't want it Casey wants to
know it sound like it's too curious huh
I'm gonna buy the the right stuff for
the kid we'll just buy a bunch of
gender-neutral students black way to
read and plus the baby the Boykin light
pink if he wants to like pink and the
girl from the beginning it's all the
same [ __ ] right right pretty much
onesies I might do a troll gender reveal
video just reviews though that's pretty
good well nothing well I mean I want to
do something you guys are in France yes
I can't have to convince cheer to be
down nine percent but I wanted to do
like a fake gender reveal video have it
look Madri Oh like nice music and [ __ ]
though a little gathering and when the
when the powder or whatever the [ __ ]
goes off it's green and everyone's
confused and then the alien comes out of
Chios body and attacks do that story not
sick that's dull so I wanted to be like
a huge troll like everyone's like oh
[ __ ] gender-reveal party at Stefan like
jenna real party like surprise or some
[ __ ] and
and then it ends up being like an alien
just kills a buddy at the party so I'm
trying to convince Chia to be it down
you'd be dealing with the pregnant lady
didn't [ __ ] oh yeah wait wait I
wouldn't mean yeah no my buddy's my
buddy's gonna check his heart up right
now and it's [ __ ] he like full on I
was at her you serious what you promised
was her birthday I was at her birthday
and this catch the next meet he's like
holy [ __ ] man you're [ __ ] in for it
you have no idea
Jonathan battery Philadelphia is it that
scary no he was like dude this [ __ ] is
throwing up every morning things I
didn't have bad no be honest be honest
be honest be honest and bars they look
at the pain in his eyes don't be honest
dammit answer correctly answer correctly
is honesty no you're serious I don't
want to be I want to know hey you're
just let the more aggravating you're
usually use like I don't do that right
right yeah you [ __ ] force down right
now maybe you just busted like what are
you talking about yeah
I guess so and I don't know it worked
fast in the Mexican yeah a true yay
we'll see in the mix if it works fast in
the Mexican 5 my location
[Music]
[Music]